على القطن والصوف ماشا تيمور الكتان أو الوطن على
صورة
وهذا عمره 3 سنوات لذا قم بتعميق الواصلة
التندرا للطعام والضحك
بديل وهذا هو kubrick مقسم السعر وليس روجر
يكتنفه عاليه التتابع والمغص او المهمة
الغول أو لا يهمني لقد تعرضت للهجوم في العمل
لحظة وراء الغابات الله هذا كشخص
بخجل في الفناء كنت في السيارات حتى
أودي بعض اطلاق النار متضخمة
الروح والعمل في الصالة لا يكفي
موطن لوسائل الإعلام وعند الأنهار الفور شامل
الروسية unox el ayran لهم ملفات العجول و
تحية لاثنين
chabad في موديلات ثانوية في يحب ترك أ
مزق شخص ما المجالات في تسلق السجون
himmat هو شاب ، لكنهم ركضوا بعد ذلك
الجليد نفسه الطاعون
رحلة وايت هو موعد مارا و
كانت هناك دموع في موغيليف
عمري قبة نيكولاي عمري 48 سنة 17 سنة
لقد بدأت العمل كموظف وليس
آسف لمدة 31 عامًا و 30 عامًا كنا معًا
أعيش مع زوجي ، ولدينا سبعة أطفال تبلغ أعمارهم 19 عامًا
قبل خدمة رائعة لا تزال
حتى الآن بقي هذا الفرح في الداخل
أن لدينا مساكننا الخاصة بها وكذلك
شراء شقة باهظة الثمن
من عامل محترف حتى يغطي
لا اشمئزاز
ما زلت متزوجة بذكاء و
بعد أن تشعر بالراحة الشديدة ، يصبح كل شيء دافئًا
يجب أن يأتي منا
تحتاج إلى غسل الأطباق بسرعة
الماء يجعلنا 10 عندما نخرج
لجلب هذا الثلج
لدرجة أن هناك ما يكفي من البنادق في كل مكان
غسلها المطبوخ وتنظيفها هنا
لا يزال من الممكن أن يكون هذا الشخص يئن جدًا
يحتاج إلى القيام بالتمثيل
تحية أوليفر allelopathy فقط لهم
قاتل و
الانتقال إلى البحر الكنسي للخليل
أو لهجة
بنقرة من الرسغ ما يدور
الرهان من قبل
أنا أغطي ما تأكله في غرفة الطعام
حصلت إذا كنت بحاجة إلى غسل رجل هنا
هؤلاء هم كل الرؤساء ، يزيلون المظلة
أنا أعطيه
اجتاز 1 هو نفسه إذا
تدور في الحمام هناك
أنا مزرر
تتكشف
يلعب الأطفال هذا
[موسيقى]
ثم في المساء اتضح أنك ستتخلص
غرف نوم الغزل
كل ذلك في نفس الغرفة وكيف
اتضح أنك وضعت بسبب
أنه لا يوجد غيره
عملنا حياتنا والجواب بالسمع
يوم عطلة بعض السبت الأحد
لم أفعل أي شيء لم أهتم به
أقوم بتسخين الموقد ، اتضح أنني سوف أتجمد
لم يقرعني الماء لأشرب. أنا أيضا
العمل وكل خمول يديره
وجدت نفسي صغيرة جدًا في الخريف
يمكن للغزل المعذب أن يراه من 100 إلى
إما أنه ضاع أو ضُرب هناك
مكث وظل معنا لمدة أربع سنوات
الأرواح
يعرف صوتي ياتي لي ضع
عندما يأتي بجواري دائمًا في الصباح
الأماكن والوقوف بالفعل وإلقاءها واستدار هناك شيء
يأتي إليك بالفعل يسمع أنه بالفعل على الفور
يأتي ويبدأ في النخر
مثل هذا الشخص على خطأ أو أنه ليس كذلك في الحقيقة
كيف يكون هذا أجر لا تحبه
كما تعلم ، أنا أحبه كثيرًا ، مثل رمادتي
طيبون حنون عندما يقولون ذلك
أحتاج إلى كسب المال حتى أعمل
هؤلاء أناس غير سعداء عندما لا تعمل
من أجل المال ومن أجل هذه الحيوانات
ثم نصبح أكثر إثارة للاهتمام
العمل والعمل بالفعل متقاعد ولكن
جرح اعتزال في مدينة بطاقة 10
هل يمكنني الذهاب الدراما لوسيوس التندرا
من الجبهة ، هنا 1 سم ، البحث عن الفاكر هو بالفعل عذراء و
مثل هذا الصمام الثنائي وضع علامة El alma de على المستوى 1
التندرا في المطبخ المتراكمة السيوف من المجموع
سوف تصبح مدينة كلمة واحدة
فترة الصبي حتى أنظر إلى مدينة هتلر
مغادرة
وأنت على وجه التحديد لبعض الوقت القصير
آسف لمغادرة وبعد ذلك. لأن الأمهات
يركض حولك
كل فريق يمشي ، يمشي ، انظر ، يقول
[موسيقى]
توربين ألينا أو
الكيميائيين يركبون رويال كيدز بابلو هراء
التراتيل تليها خايم توجولوكوف و
يفقس الصلاة من أجل شراب الفرح
هل يكفي أن تعطيني
لم ننتهي من المدرسة
من طلب
وصل
حسنًا ، لقد فاته الأطفال كثيرًا
دون دوافع النوم على تقديرها أدفع
لنبني
تفتح كيف هناك للتعامل مع السد مع الألغام
آمال
[موسيقى]
رائحته مثل
صوت قوي جدا لرؤية بالفعل من قبل
يجب أن تكون هذه الدرجة لاسو بلدي وليس
رسالة من أو الدموع التي لدينا لي
قناع توربو
لم ألاحظ أن الأمر صعب للغاية هنا
اتضح فقط غارقة في نزهة
عاصفة ثلجية سنواجه الريح بالنسبة لي
بالطبع العيون تسد الوجه كل شيء يؤلم
عيون تحترق ولكن لا شيء شيء رهيب
لم يجلب الماء الثقيل شيئًا واحدًا
على استعداد لأكل أي شيء رهيب
ثم عندما تزوجت عندما تزوجت
ظهر الطفل عندما أدركت ذلك
نفدت هنا و costco الطابور الثابت 5
ضع البرك ، ما زلت تدير الحشد
بالفعل سيئة للغاية
[موسيقى]
مؤلف واحد وجديد
غير مدربين يخشون أن يكونوا قريبين منهم
اتصل أنه كان لديه هذا لمدة 3 أيام
الوقت الذي أردت فيه البقاء في المدينة
أراد الجميع أن يكون مصفف شعر أو ممثلة
مرتبة لتكون بين أيدينا في مكان ما
شهر ونصف ربما عمل الزوجان
شعر البائع أنني سأفعل
فقط في قفص يعجبني أريد أريد أنا
أريد أن أهرب مرة أخرى
ساعاتك بعيدًا عن العبث للأطفال
الفتيات لا يتوقعن نصف قطر صغير
مفاجأة يا ابن أخي جليسة الأطفال
من يبلغ من العمر عامًا صعبًا جدًا بشكل عام و
خائف بطريقة ما على الأطفال أنك حتى أنا
الأغاني تحترق مثل موقد
الشواطئ تبكي علي
قتال أم لا
سابقة بمعنى البيئة
[موسيقى]
مقالات
لدي طفل صغير يبكي معه
حسنًا ، أنا لست غريبًا في الرجل
لأنهم يعتقدون أنك ستجيب
أنا في حاجة إليه
الخيط بشكل عام صعب جدًا أو جيد
كل شيء يبتل
أنا بالفعل سمكة تونة لماذا اختفيت هنا
هنا خرج السياج الشباب كل شيء وهلم جرا
بالكاد بدأت تتدهور
في كثير من الأحيان على الساخن سيصبح هذا الضوء
[موسيقى]
لدينا شقة ولكننا نعمل هنا
نحن نعيش معظم حياتنا هنا
شقة التندرا ملكي أنا فقط بحاجة إليها
خلال الإجازات والإقامة المؤقتة
الأمر كذلك تمامًا ، فاشتراكك هنا
حياتنا حقيقية هنا كل شيء يشبه
طفولة أطفالنا معشبة للغاية هنا
التندرا من الصعب بالتأكيد تربية الأطفال
ومن الصعب أن تنمو
لا تزال هناك حاجة للأطفال
كان لدينا سبعة لم نفعل شيئًا
تسمع أطفالنا التعامل أنا سيئة و
الأطباء وألفا ثم يوليو أنا أو
سيذهب طلب فيلم khalip في مكان ما هنا
والتبغ لي اثنين أو زميلي في الغرفة
غمس نعم وموضوع واحد حتى الوشم بها
أليس أنت هنا على رؤساء بلديات الصيد الوخز
صحيح كذلك في أفلام wma أو wav أو aiff
حب المضادات الحيوية عندما يكون الطقس سيئا
عندما يكون البلغم مثير للاشمئزاز بالطبع
لا أحد يستمتع بهذا الطقس من قبل
تبللت الخيوط في الليل ولا تزال بحاجة إلى ذلك
الوصول إلى المكان ثم إحداث ضوضاء و
عندما تقوم بإذابة الموقد بعد ذلك
فقط الحصول على الدفء كنت تعرف ذلك أو
عندما الصقيع عند 40 50 درجة لا يكفي
من السهل القول
[موسيقى]
العالم ما تقوله صعب جدا
احيانا تبكي احيانا
في بعض الأحيان تتساءل متى سينتهي كل هذا
يمكن أن ينمو pinchuk لا يعني لدينا
لقد كبر أطفالنا أيضًا
ينمو الأحفاد بشكل طبيعي أيضًا
جزع العقل وترك que no hoshi o ou
هي تونسية وبفتا
كوليف يأمر بألفا نهائية أنت على حسابي
هذا من mts و fio smoke java loss arina
عندما تكون جالسًا بالفعل على الموقد
دافئ وجلوس على الشاي الساخن شرب ذلك
يبدو بالفعل أنه منسي بالفعل
تزوجت بشكل جيد ، يمكنك الاستمرار في العمل ومرة ​​أخرى
في الصباح أيضا الاستيقاظ ومرة ​​أخرى أنت بالفعل
طبخ
وباستمرار مثل هذه الدورة باستمرار
[موسيقى]
نجل و مرة نأتي مرة أخرى
من فضلك لا يمكن أن يقف في انتظارك gnu
العامة بوريس هناك أو على الأقل المواد
بالأحرى إلى المكان لي ، حيوي
التحقق من الرقابة تبجح طارق آل
ماشية فاليدا و عايدة تايان لي نفس ليزا
الصراخ الغش
لنا
[موسيقى]
بشكل عاجل
الجميع يستمع
قالت أن أمي ليست لي
الرنة لي ها هي تقنية أكثر
المهتمة بالأمهات ربما تسير في الاتجاه الصحيح
الزبادي وأبي سيخبر أبي على الأقل
للتحذير وبالطبع كنا حزينين
لقد أخبره الجبل بالفعل ، نوعًا ما مثل قطعة من الدليل
الشارع الفكرة هي العمل في المدينة ، على ما يبدو
باعتباره الابن البكر للرجاء له الامم المتحدة
يبقى فقط ربما لم يغضب
قال ذلك
لكنه اختياره يمكننا أن نكون الآن
يوما ما سوف يتقاعد زوجه
سيكون من الصعب بدوني
مثل هذا الألم مع العلم أنك أهدأ منه هنا
لا غزال
أنا مرتبط جدا به أنا جدا
افتقد كل الأطفال هم نفس الشيء عندما
واحد منهم هو بداية بعيدة جدا
أتوق إلى معرفة أطفالي فقط
إنهم يتوقون إلى أنهم لا يبتعدون عن بعضهم البعض أبدًا
صديق لا يزيد عن سطر واحد
يشبه الكيمياء
متماسكة جدا مرنة
انسكاب نعم على ما يبدو
أي . بدأت في المغادرة
تتزوج الفتيات الحمد لله ورقة
لم تذهب بعيدا
سحابة أنا
هنا
كل المواضيع
لذلك يبدو أننا كنا بالفعل
الكبار هي طفل صغير عندما
طفل يفكر يعوي لماذا كان عمره 43 سنة
الأطفال
الأقران لديهم بالفعل أطفال كبروا أرجلهم
هناك دعنا نقول لك حياتك الهادئة أ
عندما يأتي الطفل ، أعانقك
ذهبي
ماما
أنت المفضل لدي
كيف يمكنك أن تفكر لماذا
43 سنة ولدت عايز 50 أنجبت
[موسيقى]
ريجينا
نحن مستاؤون بالطبع لأن الأطفال
يبدو أكثر أدوات الحوت الجميع
الهواتف
الإنترنت سوف يذهبون مباشرة ، سيكونون جميعًا كاملين
لأيام يمكنهم الجلوس على الهاتف ، وإذا جلسوا
الهاتف لا يعرفون ماذا يفعلون
الأطفال هم نوع من الزومبي الجدد
ما هو مع هذه الهواتف
سيء جدا بالطبع
لا أعرف كيف أتعامل معها
الحضارة هي عادة المشي
وشيء ما يتغير
بعض الأماكن التي بدأت بخصوصها
الجليد annino
إنه محزن بالفعل
حياتنا حقيقية يجب أن يكون كل شيء
كما ينبغى
لكنه يختفي ببطء ويختفي
[موسيقى]
انها ليست هنا عادة
يأكل
مر الصيف في ثلاثة أشهر سيعود مع
من الداخل
هذا يجعلني سعيدا جدا ، أنا لا أحب الشتاء
أنتظر هذا الشتاء لأنني أعرف ماذا لو
الشتاء ، مما يعني أنه سيكون في المنزل بالفعل
[موسيقى]
اطبعها فقط حاول أن تنسى
كيف لا تنتظر الوقت الذي تنتظر فيه
الوقت طويل جدا
لا تغفل عنه أنك لا تفتقده
القيام بأعمال تجارية هناك
حتى يأكلني تلك على الفور
الشغل
أكل بعد العمل
كن بين الزبدة
في دور نظام التشغيل العمل صعب للغاية ولكن
ومن جمع اليوم تحت
متعب العمر أعرف قطع حزام
[موسيقى]
أنا أعمل منذ 38 عامًا 14
الصف 4 الانتهاء من الخرق ، انتقلنا
ربما لديك غزال ، ثم إنه قادم بالفعل
اختيار طرف جيل
الزاحف الماضي
لمقاومة قراءة الجيلات أستانا سيساعدنا
منزل بالطبع
سيعود اليك سترى الابن
تخطط للبقاء
أثناء التخطيط لا أعرف عن حفيف
غيرت رايي
قررنا أبي وقراره بالكامل
دعه يقرر
إذا كان يريد المدينة فلن نفعل ذلك
وقفة احتجاجية
غادر المدرسة في وقت مبكر جاء معنا
التندرا منذ الطفولة ما العمل الشاق
كنت
نأسف لأننا سمحنا له
تصل في وقت سابق أيضا
بدأ العمل عليه
لا تعتمد على المدة التي عملت فيها
هناك على مدار الساعة هناك حتى تتعامل
هل يعتمد الغزلان في كثير من الأحيان
في الليل نتحرك العرف
.
كلمة الطقس لا يهم الآن إذا
الذين يصعب عليهم رباني
ليقول
أبلغ من العمر ثلاثين عامًا ، لذا يمكنني شم الرائحة أكثر
لأكون صادقًا ، لا أرى مثل هذا الأنف ، نعم سأذهب
على الطريق أعرف الطريق بكل الطرق
للحد من هذا الدمدمة في مكان ما
انظر ماذا يجري وأنا
أماكن صغيرة جدًا 2 لأنني أملك
نعمل باستمرار ذهابًا وإيابًا نذهب إلى مكان ما
الأعمال المنزلية إذا حدث ذلك فجأة
يترك الرجال القطيع كله ويقولون
سوف تكون اليوم على سبيل المثال لن أستسلم
upekut look ثم أنا من القلب
أنا أدرس على الرنة سألقي نظرة هناك
سأبحث عن أماكن مثل هذه ، سأرى وهكذا
قريبًا دائمًا مما أبكي كثيرًا
أود أن يأتي في وقت لاحق ليس تماما هنا هو البركة
نعم الطبيعة ليست جميلة ابدا
جميله وحقا لا اريد الذهاب الان
هناك الكثير من الناس في المدينة
[موسيقى]
لنا هنا لواء قليل من قومه
نعرف بعضنا البعض ولسنا خائفين
أولادكم من مدينة آدم قادمون أنا
لا تعرف تأثير أطفال المساء
يذهبون أنا قلق للغاية لسبب ما
من الصعب جدا التعود على هذا المجتمع
[موسيقى]
FINi العثور على حوالي 100 مقال في العالم
التندرا wotofo court a y or ng i
تذكارات أو ولاعة رافال من فالا
فيلم miller madina tom de rossi and
هذه الخلفية ولوحة حقائق الفرج أحلى
جدا جدا
وطائرة الهليكوبتر أسهل بالطبع للأطفال
جمع منا في
شكل من أشكال التقدم
إذا كانت على مركبة صالحة لجميع التضاريس ، فهي حرفياً ثلاثة أيام
ربما سيكون من الضروري جمع ثم أكثر
للذهاب إلى فوركوتا كم يهتز ويدخل
البرد على الأطفال نفس الضجيج يقضون الليل
لذلك جاءوا بطائرات هليكوبتر ، إنها غاية في الأهمية
مريح وجيد نعم مع لوائنا
اثنان من الطلاب سوف تطير فيرونيكا ستطير
المحارب أنت أولادي هم فقط معهم
يطيرون بي ، سوف نرتب الفتيات ، سوف نعلق
أحد الأقارب والعودة
إرجاع
بالطبع سأفتقد البقاء هنا
غادرنا.
تسليم وظيفتي لماذا أفتقد بالفعل
قد يكون بعض عمله
خاطئ - ظلم - يظلم
أفتقد حقًا أنه تبين أن الخريف هو أمي
ممزق في اثنين أفتقدك
الأطفال لأنهم يعيشون هناك مثل المدرسة
لا يوجد حتى الآن اتصالات و
تفتقد العمل ولا يبدو أنك تعلم
الجو خانق هنا في مدرسة دانيل الحقيقية
سأذهب بالتأكيد سأذهب بعد ذلك
سأترك العمل وأقوم بذلك
المدرسة وبالتالي تيموثاوس سيذهب ويكون
بجانبهم حتى سكب بالفعل خطأ
التي مزقتها باستمرار من كبار السن
نفسي والآن عندما أتذكر الفتاة
من الأفضل ألا أتذكر سيئتي عندما
عندما تركت روفرز جرعات حولا ولم تفعل
حتى يتوق فقط للرسائل
مراسلة والفتيات معك هناك
حاول شيء ما في المنزل أن يعيش
لا أريد مثل هذا الوقت الحزين
لا ينبغي أن نتذكر أنهم يخبروننا أننا حلمنا
حتى تتمكن من الذهاب معنا أنت دائمًا
يعتقد أن عائلتنا هي سلسلة دبابات
لا ينفصم ولا ينبغي أن يكون
يجب أن يكون صديقي دائمًا معًا
عوالم ومهام وتحركات
يوم صورة كبير الخدم أو نوع آخر من مالبوس
زملاء رو احترام طريقة الحياة بعد ذلك
كيف تنفق الكونياك ، الجميع يملكها
يعتقد بعض الناس أنهم رائعون ، فماذا عنك؟
أنت تتحدث عنه
قبلة
أعين على نوع جديد من Levicheva مرة أخرى لا أفعل
[موسيقى]
فريق
بلدي الوحيد على الرجل juke sexy
دفع يمكن أن تضخم الطريق جدا
[موسيقى]
سوف تنتظر في روسيا أن هذه هي نفسها
السياسة الجيدة يسكب ماء الصقيع بشكل ضعيف
و forik u عمل فوز له مدخل الغداء و
على badoo
انا ارسلت
وصور ترويضهم وهذه هي القطعان و
لعبة الطفيليات لماذا تعملون
لسبب ما لا يعمل من أجلك
أنت تقوم برحلتين من أجل اللحوم ، هذا ليس كل شيء
أفهم أنني لعبة حية وخفقت
لذلك ، يتم حلزون دقة نفس المكان
ليفربول هذا الذي وقف هنا جاء
شم لي وتخميني ما كنت تقوله
إنه مثل هذا الحساب الذي يفهمه أقول له
قطيع من الأفكار لا تبحث عن أمي
حسنًا ، ندمت على كل شيء وغادر المروحية
طار ، ورأيت أنه كان يركض إلى الجانب
طاعون
لقد طرت بالفعل بعيدًا ولكن حان الوقت لابنتي
يقول الله لنفسي يا أفريقيا
إنه يفتقده لترك الأمر يجعل الأمر أسهل
لقضية لحم حب ركبتي لا يفهمها الناس
هو ، مثل طفل ورجل بالغ ، أدين
الزوجان يعانيان معي على أي حال
نشأ لي الآخرون وهم يلصقون العيش
تغذية جيدة اعتنى بها أيضا
كانت بالفعل وليست صحيحة تمامًا.
حقيقة أنه لا يوجد الآن أي فكرة عن البعوض
يزرع مراحل وهو بالفعل يرعاني
[موسيقى]
أنت
مرحبًا فيرا سيرجي جورجيفيتش
هذا هو اللواء الخامس
سيرجي جورجييفيتش نقف على الميناء و
اين كنت العام الماضي
براغ ويقول
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سجل نعم
انه واضح
بعد غد
في الصباح أو أيا كان
برغم من
بشكل عام ، فإن المروحية لا
غدا أو بعد غد لا توجد مروحية
بعض الجنسي
2 على لا
يوم آخر في رأيي
فيرونيكا مثل أكثر
من ولاعة
boing ما زالت تلك السن
عاطفي جدا
يبدأ الحزن في البكاء على الفور
فيرونيكا أكثر حداثة أو بطريقة أو بأخرى
سأبكي أيضًا ، نعم ، أنا نفسي ، على ما يبدو ،
باختصار والشر
جدا لا تجلس
[موسيقى]
انا ضعيف وانا بنت دنيا بيزي التفاصيل
إعادة المرأة
لكن
نحن
[موسيقى]
أنا
تقول من أين أنت
الاستثمار في ذلك أعتقد أننا
نستثمر في أرباح الأبناء والحب ليس كذلك
وضعها فيها بحيث تكون تحت سن الشيخوخة
أنت عادت Lyubushkina ، لم أفعل
قالوا إن والدك جاء
لم يصبح النهر بعد 50 بالفعل
حصلنا على هذا المثال من الملاكمة
تجد قل لي على ما يبدو إذا 7 حب
الحب والحصاد
سيتم النظر إليه عندما تكون نيكولاي
نجله كسر فكرة الحجاب والمغذي الألمان
فيلم peddinghaus وحده بينما لا خبطت
التندرا
أماليا والرماد من تلك الروح هنا هو وحيد
المجارف BT
[موسيقى]
كل شيء يتغير ألين لا يتغير
انها قبيحة
وهربنا مرة أخرى ، سنكون في المقدمة
وون
إنطلق
[موسيقى]